In addition to coding APIs that
are functional and high performing,
documentation should be easy to
navigate, and aesthetically pleasing.
If your documentation looks like
classified ads from a newspaper,
developers are not going to be
eager to navigate through it.
Let's take a look at Twilio's
documentation for using their API.
Tulio has this overview page, which
easily guides developers to the major
aspects of their API without
getting lost in the documentation.
Some API providers like Udacity, for
instance, use what we call Hello World
documentation containing boiler plate
code for using their APIs quickly.
Having a section for
frequently asked questions, like
the Google Maps API, makes it easy for
developers to quickly get answers
to their most common questions.
In some situations a good FAQ section
can be just as informative as
the original documentation.
Since it addresses constraints and
common corner cases of a system.
Playgrounds and sand boxes are also
great tool sets many API providers
are adding to their documentation.
Developers can test out API end points
by executing sample API request
directly on the providers web site.
When developing your own APIs, consider
taking time to make fun, interactive and
develop-friendly documentation in order
to gain popularity amongst your users.